I can't your boy psychobabble and we're  gonna do some tank maham [ __ ] it's a  nice car you feel like blowing [ __ ] up  James down the route the morning start  users to deliver their goods buried in  the syndicate by your sing with a few  pipe bombs under them hot that I'm  saying we use it Hank this may be the  best idea you've ever had this car  [ __ ] sokka's dare call like a literal  like there's a hole that punt I in there  okay let's tear that sunshine i hate  breaking the window but yeah that's what  you gotta do sometimes okay ouch not the  right [ __ ]  okay okay  just like the ages which I've ever seen  ok  chef  this is so dope I guess  ok thank you thank you  dips out for Harambee